Mình sau tháng tư, tôi thống như đường trăm tổ chứ khó báo tại nhà trắng.
Căng lời chính xích giải kêu phi công em mới lắm em tại ira lắm trong những vụ tìm kiem kêu nạn
có tạm và phía một nhất trong lịch sử của lỗi Mỹ.
Theo thống tìm được công bố em lắm em em lắm em khi bây giờ có 2 thêm kia phía đoàn.
Trong khi người mọi buồn trước đã được giải kêu sấm.
Tìm công buồn sau đã phải lần tránh lộ truy tìm, nhưng đất đần buồn mới tạm sẽ tế lắm trước khi được giải kêu.
Tôi thống nghĩ cho biết đã chuyển khá chính xích với phía một lớn,
kết hợp lực lượng là kia, trước tháng mấy bài trình đấu và các biển pháng nghiving nhằm lạnh lạc lực đường phương.
Sau đó, xuất khó lạnh thổ ira mặt không chứ tổn thích nhận sử,
tôi nhìn phía ira cho biết đã sử dã ra ra tránh trực biệt tại thành is phá hàn khi lửa lượng lương này,
truy tìm, khi cóm, khiến buồn xích quanh thế mạng trong đó có một trình đường.
Tìm ra cũng đến bố đã bàn trống một số mục tiêu của Mỹ trong khi Washington cẳng đình tự tài phá quyền
nhập phương tiện của chính mình để tránh dư rơi phá tài đường phương.
Chứ dịch được từ khiến sau khi tìm tích át mới làm em bị bàn dựng in một bà thần tư,
mình đã vi động hàng trăm mì sẽ cũng hả trụ mấy bài trình như vô.
Trong đó có sự có hả mề bà bật tài không thích tất cả những khiến trống bị vôc phá quy, để hiện trường.